there seems to be some commotion coming
from what makes life worth living The
Last of Us tries to answer that question
by giving us a vision of a world that
makes no room for people to really live
their lives anymore in this post
pandemic military ruled society the most
anyone can hope for is merely to survive
and as many characters in the game know
in a world where the survival of any one
from one day to the next is uncertain
attachments connections love these
things can become liabilities these
things can destroy you
Naughty Dog's a claimed action game has
made its way to the PlayStation 4 as the
Last of Us remastered and if you played
the game on the PlayStation 3 you'll
probably notice that it runs at a higher
framerate and that the lighting is
richer and moodier in this release in
side-by-side comparisons it also becomes
apparent that the textures are sharper
and the draw distance has been increased
but the reality is that the game already
looked so good on the PlayStation 3 that
the visual enhancements can't do all
that much to improve your experience the
Last of Us remastered is still the last
of us and that is no bad thing it's one
of the best adventures of the last
console generation and it's fully
deserving of the special edition
treatment it gets here perhaps nobody
knows the dangers of loving others in
this uncertain world better than Joel
the protagonist of The Last of Us a hard
bitter man Joel isn't likable but he is
at least understandable in large part
because the dialogue in the Last of Us
is so human and believable what are we
doing here this is not us do you know
about us mommy I know that you are
smarter than this really guess what
we're shady people joel has been that
way for a long time we are survival
society it is over Tess and although
that humanity comes through in all of
the game's major characters it's the
teenager Ellie who is the game's
emotional heart in contrast to Joel's
cynicism
Elly is still capable of wide-eyed
wonder while Joel seems dead inside Elly
is very much alive and over the course
of the game
neither Joel nor you can avoid growing
attached to her the story is set in a
world where every human life is in
constant danger and the harrowing combat
of the game supports this feeling
whether you're fighting ordinary humans
or infected ones you're encouraged to
rely on stealth distracting enemies and
sneaking up on them to save your
precious supplies the Last of Us is not
a game in which you can boldly charge at
your enemies with guns blazing instead
you rummage through every abandoned
house store and workplace looking for
things you can use to craft weapons and
health kits because every enemy poses a
serious threat there's a real fear of
being spotted or of an enemy coming at
you from behind so you try to stay aware
of your surroundings
one type of infected the clickers see by
using echolocation and the sound of
their clicking is unsettling enough to
make your skin crawl as in the
PlayStation 3 version the tension of
combat is sometimes undermined by your
allies behaving erratically doing things
that would get you spotted and killed on
the other hand there are moments in
which your companions behavior creates
the feeling that you're not alone on
this journey such as when Ellie comes to
your rescue by stabbing your assailant
in the back the Last of Us remastered
includes the original games multiplayer
mode along with all of the map packs
that were released as DLC the
multiplayer successfully captures the
unnerving feeling of the single-player
combat and wraps it up in an engaging
meta game about trying to sustain a camp
full of survivors by gathering supplies
and completing specific tasks during
missions you can give them out an extra
emotional punch by linking it to your
personal Facebook account enabling you
to see updates about your real-life
friends dying as your camp flounders and
then there's left behind the
extraordinary DLC chapter for the Last
of Us unlocked here from the beginning
while the main game's narrative concerns
with the importance of interpersonal
connections and the gameplays focus on
combat and violence are somewhat at odds
with each other left behind takes the
established mechanics of The Last of Us
and uses them to support its story of
the bond between Ellie and her friend
Riley playing as Ellie you and Riley
toss bricks at car windows hunt each
other with water pistols and do other
things together and all the while the
characters really talk to each other
laugh with each other get angry with
each other and do other things that real
people do left behind has real character
development and real emotional payoff
The Last of Us is a great action game
that you should play if you haven't
already and if you have played it before
the improvements here aren't so dramatic
as to make the game feel like a new
experience but it is definitely one
worth revisiting in the world of The
Last of Us as in our world love might
destroy you but it's also one of the
only things worth really fighting for